nearly two months ago five cyclists were
killed in a crash near searchlight
while the driver involved is charged
with dui clark county is trying to
improve road safety today commissioner
justin jones was proposing
updated laws for cyclists the ordinance
he's proposing clarifies when a cyclist
has the right to use an entire travel
lane on county roads
clark county is considering new signs
with that message saying
cyclists may use an entire lane
it's a minor tweak our ordinance to make
it clear
that cyclists can use the full lane uh
under certain circumstances
okay uh i'm not opposed to that
jones says clark county is working with
the southern nevada bicycle
coalition ndot and other organizations
to make other safety improvements
the ordinance about that sign gets a
public hearing february 16th
also you may notice these around town
their billboards along i-15 reminding
you
and you're driving to change lanes for
bikes
it was put up by the las vegas cyclist
memorial in partnership with olympia
companies local home builder